[Music]
hi guys Samuel leads here I'm with my
brother and business partner Russell and
we are standing outside a castle how's
it feel Russ to own all this line around
this castle
it's pretty amazing really Oh every time
I see it very often they do it so we've
probably it's probably lived with what
two three months since we last saw it
every time we come there's always things
going on there's always massive
progressions but of course with a
building like this this size it's it's a
it's a slow process there's a lot of
things tough to do the last time we came
we've got all the conservation officers
out here they'd agreed on the fact that
we could we could run it how we want you
to run it that agreed on most of the
works so we can see there's a lot going
on we've now got scouting literally all
around the castle well then a lot of the
trees drop chopped down that were
outside the windows which have now gone
because they were blocking the light
from inside the castle but I'm really
hoping to see last time I was here our
project manager Chris he said that we'd
be able to get in every every room which
is great because normally it's like
there's a lot of the rooms oh well even
on the survey on the plans everything
we've got there's some bits is just like
out of action it's like you know or
knows no no one knows because no one's
been in those rooms for decades and
decades because it's completely unsafe
but now if all the floors will be put
into say work we can get around yeah so
I'm hoping to be able to just get to the
top of the castle have a good look
around a good proper look down it'd be
safe I want to get a really good idea of
how it's been configured I mean that's
come in yeah
working out with what we need to do now
is well the purpose of this meeting is
now it's safe we can actually get around
the building will it to work out what
rooms going to be what what what's the
break you're gonna be how many bedrooms
are gonna be in each apartment and where
we're gonna put the on sweets as
although it's gonna be quite a long time
probably the end of this year before the
interior actually starts to it'll be
nice to be able to feel it and say you
know we like this and we can start
visualizing it and maybe I'll tell you
what as well like this is going to plan
like normally when you take on big
projects there's there's always things
that go wrong but so far this is going
really quite smoothly
yeah so fingers crossed that will
continue to be the case you have to
expect problems when you're doing
properties this big so we've got no big
problems yet and you know everything
seems to be going well but I'm learning
about you learning a lot actually I have
a look
[Music]
this looks a lot clearer
this is which is why lose lots of water
but I did my servers lots of water
perhaps but we couldn't actually get to
it yeah
it's the first time I've been able to
get right up to the very top of the
castle and absolutely glorious great
views really really good to go to see it
from a totally different perspective
[Music]
so the outside of the castle has finally
been cotton salted we're known as that
cannot be doing the works will be
carried out and done now now which one
work out what's actually gonna happen on
the inside and we're just working out
exactly how we're gonna divide the
apartments or we're going to use as a
bedroom we're going to use the sitting
rooms where the kitchen is going to bake
light on the stuff so Spencer who spent
months talking about this but I think we
just need to call good decisions and
massive role this is big but if we make
it absolutely ridiculous oh there's
actually a bedroom but then you've got a
big walk-in wardrobe all of us will be
opened up like stand up in the morning
they'll come into that wardrobe there'll
be a massive beautiful view with little
lights back here is a humongous what
falsely on sweep beautiful big back that
way continue some of these apartments
which is in this apartment 3 Ted Cruz
area which is kitchen dot massive
glorious humongous bedroom with a
limited wardrobe I'm really not big back
ensuite and then I guess have a little
bathroom a little bedroom I've made this
a thing is was to beat your balance of
how this is feel
okay who's been off middle or the
populous hotel or you know someone make
someone who wants to feel like a king in
a castle but they don't want to wait any
longer
all that so inconvenience is to the
rooms need to be to a castle walking in
ground floor massive human lives without
all the hassle what if some people may
be business people professionals or what
they said they retire the [ __ ] marry you
no not necessarily not be glamorous
facility wealthy couples that want to
live of my life yeah this brush their
kids ah
just let that one on that morning
serious company level put 18 lithium
battery cameras so without a power
supply and also remotely the make it
remotely open solitary something ask you
something
you still walking through this door no
so that's all there is here and then
this has a preview access absolute
search access right here leading free
yeah bedroom bedroom ensuite bedroom
nice
[Applause]
it was okay cause it's like [ __ ] so you
can see where the holes were reported
over much debate yeah there's only one
error there's still a hole in it because
it's extensive dry rot and we need
listed built with a sense to deal with a
scene where they they can't be tripping
that ceiling down yeah so a moment these
before notice you can't look into it we
shortly see from the stairway I'll show
you that room now yeah and everybody
becomes he gets inducted as to where the
danger areas are and then it's safer for
contractor to be here it's not safe the
general public too long will the
contractors be here will be named
packages so contractors are popping in
and out doing surveys and things so
they're the people we need to maintain
safety so on the top floor at the moment
we could never previously get onto this
floor because it was absolutely
dangerous as happy so now it's safe this
is still the top floor still needs doing
the most work by a long way we've got
birds and stuff so it's still a little
bit creepy but at least we can walk
around and down see it safe here so you
can see that there's a damage and it's
coming from the valley this it's safe on
this side with us um that that's props
this blue but this pyramid is bit apart
off for safety it's just a bit to try
and get really rude room this is what is
what German German gentleman
bedroom night so what's all this - yeah
it's got same again that's just got all
the water taxi
there's no yeah so you think that you'll
get a nice big bedroom over there which
is down yeah yeah well what's the
problem at once having been through this
yeah is your kitchen without massive
broke kitchen Donna you should know
you're downstairs okay so that's what
six this out downstairs on this floor
first days as this plan six goes off and
then this was all flat six as well but
you could split again sort of flat six
into it yeah is that we gonna put one
apartment it's a tiny it's at this bit
then I even how do you get up these
stairs kitchen about yeah what's going
on how do you access the tower the other
side we're gonna we're on the right side
of the building this house runs on
because that's cool that you can access
the tower it's quite a good selling
point
we've got swimming pool one of the other
grounds yeah you think
[Music]
[Music]
in the kitchen
interceptor distress also remembers
kitchen
I think yes Island kitchens it's just
the way to go this food is so what we
planned
yeah that's the max if you got other
words I love this island yeah because
we're living here the best views and
also access to the tower so what what
month would you predict your baby before
there's a paintbrush lifted externally
probably nine turn love in certainly
September yes June so maybe around about
juniors when we start actually about the
outside of them's call it done but we
now need start getting the presentation
on there
don't worry
so and I don't hold me to it but we'll
do our best to get the roof and walls
[Music]
what we contain sivanna penguin
he resolved it
[Music]
it's very much a tomorrow
say how it comes out with everybody bowl
there's too many variables to give you
straight answers
yeah learners so much I mean just do a
reaper usually the reaper whatever you
learn a lot but everything are building
like this I have learned so much I think
it'll be worth doing the project just to
the education that I'll get for hanging
around people like these builders and
project managers fantastic what brings
love you all right so I'm gonna head
home now really happy with the progress
I think I was setting out a lot of fun
learned a lot next time we come all
these trees that are blocking the
glorious driver these trees are going to
be three foot high so we should have a
much better view when we drive in as
well so fantastic see you next time
we'll do an update probably about three
or four months time
[Music]